welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's seminar novel
application of molecular diagnostics and
infectious diseases presented by dr.
Esther babbity she is the director of
clinical operations for microbiology
services associate attending
microbiologist for the department of
medicine and Laboratory Medicine and the
director of clinical microbiology
fellowship at Memorial sloan-kettering
Cancer Center my name is Susie Valdez
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits without
further ado please join me in welcoming
our presenter dr. Esther babbity welcome
dr. reberty you may begin
thank you very much for the introduction
and thank you for the invitation to
present today as mentioned the topic of
my presentation will be on novel
applications of molecular diagnostics in
infectious disease so just to get us
started I want to just start by pointing
out some of the things we all are aware
of molecular tests have revolutionized
the diagnosis of infectious disease and
here I'm showing you some of the ways it
has happened from the very slow very
culture that took many many week
for the laboratory to obtain a result
molecular diagnosis have been able to
make this process quite fast by having
testing that is done really rapidly to
the point that these days twenty minutes
at most for many of the tests that we
use is the timeframe in which we get our
result in addition to the rapidity with
which we are able to obtain tests using
molecular diagnostic we also have an
increase in the accuracy from going to
it tests like in the FDA for example
where there is some subjectivity in
interpretation of the result with a
molecular diagnostic the objectivity and
allows for a more accurate
interpretation furthermore we have seen
a significant increase in the
sensitivity of the yesterday's so again
showing a smear where depending on the
abundance of the pathogen on the side
you may or may not get a result but with
a molecular test the sensitivity
increase in such a way that we are able
to diagnose most infections if the
pathogen is present in addition to
sensitivity the specificity of the
diagnosis has also been significantly
improved with molecular diagnostic so
much so that unlike for example CPE as
shown on this image where an
technologies had to look and decide what
the city looked like to make a diagnosis
of a viral infection with a molecular
diagnostic on the specificity of the SI
in terms of how its design allows again
for a accurate sensitive rapid and
specific result to be obtained for our
patient so we know this that the
molecular tests have really changed the
way with we've done diagnostic and this
started about almost 30 years ago at
this point and they least as things
continue to improve in terms of their
Turner and timebut
so in terms of sensitivity and
specificity as mentioned it'll be
earlier this also have been simplified
right so the original molecular tests
tend to be very cumbersome and only
available in big reference of the
current assays spend a range of simply
simplicity from the really really simple
to the really cumbersome still however
the availability of tests is shown on
the slides it's really allowed for
molecular diagnostic to be implemented
in a variety of setting so these days we
are able to talk about sample to result
platform here we've and when I hear
something that is really really exciting
and shows how much improvement and how
much development has been in this field
to the point that now even in emergency
room can do in molecular tests for
example for influenza so this word is
only good tests have really improved and
have simplified many of the current
workflow that we are aware of in
addition to this really simple sample to
result CLIA waived and point-of-care
testing there is also been approached by
many and manufacturer to help the
laboratory consolidate a lot of the
testing that we currently do on a
variety of platform to be able to
consolidate them on one platform that is
able to run for laboratory developed
tests but also the commercially
available IBD clear passing so this has
been a second improvement or one of the
multiple improvement I should say in
molecular diagnostic allowing for
automation and consolidation from the
original very manual very competent test
to what we are experiencing now in the
ability to add a sample to a platform
with minimal user input and get a result
interface into the clinical information
system so from the
original tests that were developed
almost thirty years ago to where the
field is right now it has been a
significant improvement however gap
still remains and several unmet need
still exist and because I'm from New
York City when I think about it gap I'm
obviously thinking about gap between the
subway platform and the Train and so
this is going to be the icon that I'm
using cord to talk to show some of the
gap that still exists in this field
that's already has done so much and some
of the emerging testing that is coming
to try to fill this gap so for today's
our learning objective will be that
after this presentation the burner
should be able to one describe existing
gap in the rapid diagnosis of infectious
disease be able to discuss the
advantages and limitations or some of
our current tests for the diagnosis of
infectious disease and finally be able
to list some of the emerging molecular
medicine and the potential impact on the
rapid diagnosis of infectious disease
and there's quite a few are emerging
diagnostic tool coming up in the field
however in this particular presentation
I only cover a young a few of them right
so in order to frame this discussion I'm
going to use a couple of cases to
highlight some of this gap and how some
of this new method can hopefully fail
some of these unmet need starting with
our first case so case one is that of
one year old patient with was suffering
from hemophilia static landfill
histiocytes so it's very following from
now on we call it h LH right so this is
an immune disorder and in order to treat
this patient she needed to have a bone
marrow transplant so the patient
received in a low hematopoietic stem
transplant and the mother was a donor as
followed of course um she ended up
ending chronic versus host disease or
GVHD and she also suffered from a
persistent her human herpes
very six Romania so in this graph I'm
just showing you some of her viral load
over the course of the year a few months
insula patient studied with very low
level of them but a bit lower than 10000
and then if humans within after her HST
treatment she ended up having a spike in
her viral load that went from about
10,000 to 60,000 so the question that
the clinician was asking in this
particular case and just before we moved
on but when you look at the result of
the patient in a logarithmic scale
although the raw number should a big
spike the spike by a logarithm on a
logarithmic cell was a little bit less
pronounced but yet still an increase so
the clinician then was questioning the
result and asking is this really it is
physics infection mr. pigeon viremia
weeny reflection of a disease a change
in the state of over infection and if so
is this something that will require the
patient to undergo treatment for this
particular viral infection so just like
so we are all on the same page let's
just review for a second what the
concern is ready here so HSV sex or
human herpes virus 6 is really unique
amount of herpes virus in that it can
become almost only integrated so what is
chromosomally integrated human herpes
virus so this is a condition in which
the complete genome of the virus is
integrated into the host germline and
this system vertically transmitted in a
Mendelian manner and so essentially
although this is a bowel infection the
integration of the virus into the genome
and to the X chromosome that occurred
allows it to then get transmitted like
you would any other just mutation or
genetic disease right so the X
chromosome would be given to one of the
kids a potential between the parents and
so that
mission would not necessarily a
reflection of a viral disease parade or
more of a genetic infection or a genetic
disease in this particular case this is
a little bit more highlighted on this
figure that basically shall I carry your
zone where chromosome do you look at the
telomere disco modem and you can see the
presence of the HSV 6 virus and in this
particular case is agency 6b one of the
two genotype of this virus so the
patient being positive for HSV 6 may be
just the result of an infection that's
being reactivated as with any herpes
virus or could be a reflection of the
chromosomal integration into the host
genome so how do we diagnose such as
basic settings well as we mentioned some
of the earlier improvement in molecular
diagnosis meant that we were able to
diagnose patient using real-time PCR so
for agency 6 one of the tests that we
currently use are quantitative PCR only
plasma sample so there is a lot of
advantage to this medicine but it's also
very sensitive to some of the
pre-analytical issues that are related
to maybe the processing the storage the
handling of the specimen which can use
both negative or false positive results
or even some inaccurate point ation
furthermore depending on the methodology
that is used a result of a quantitative
test obtained let's say at Memorial
sloan-kettering is very unique to that
particular assays the particular assay
in use at that facility and doesn't
necessarily translate well in terms of
being comparable to results of the
nightly difference on a different
location so in any case qualitative as
my PCR this is just showing again a
graph of a real term I see we have a
standard curve and then we get a number
right so this quantity this connotation
tend to be expressed in the copy for
meals as shown into some other side in
every courier or you can convert that to
log
his per male but again very specific to
the laboratory in which the essays being
performed to diagnose chromosomal
tributing HSV 6 however he had to go
beyond just a quantitative PCR some of
the oceans that are out there that I
available look at the hair follicle on
the fingernail clipping again looking at
the presence of these Paris in the host
genome another way would be to look and
compare the quantitative results from a
blood sample from a parent with child
and if there is a certain difference in
in the parallel between those that are
at least rather than five blogs that
would be suggestive of maybe a or viral
infection persists from oh so many and
HSV six another option will be then to
look at it is the six mRNA testing is
more of a reflection of the replicating
virus and active infection again are
primarily focused on or real-time PCR
quantitative PCR or quite they are the
way we have it done so just to summarize
a little bit of once we currently know
we have a lot of advantage every time
PCR for quantitative PCR for ferrous
fine so this has allowed us to me please
some of the combat some and sensitive
our cultural methods remember from the
earlier slide when you look at CP II
imagine having to do that for monitoring
of an infection especially qualitative
monitoring or viral load that was not a
very practical approach and so real-time
PCR has allowed us to move away from
this it allows the measurement of the
barrel or not just in plasma or whole
blood but in any other specimen type and
depending on and say the turnaround time
can be a few hour as opposed to several
weeks and we think about how our culture
works in particular for chromosome
integrated HSV six we are looking at
different methodologies would be able to
distinguish between an acute HSV six
infection and a commis already
integrated one that is not in
treatment and just summarize qPCR and
mrna are some of the target that we look
at to make that diagnosis one of the
capstan that this particular case
highlights is the fact that is quite
challenging especially for Baris to be
able to distinguish between an
integrated virus and an active infection
furthermore for many of the other herpes
virus being able to distinguish between
active and Lenten infection with the
current molecular test we have is not
always as practical and this also if
applies to other infection bacterial or
fungal infection when the target is any
being able to distinguish between
colonize or actively infected patient is
still a limitation of the current
methodology and as I briefly alluded to
it tests don't necessarily are not
necessary standardized across different
platforms so that result obtained in one
institution don't necessarily translate
to one across different situation and it
just be six are at this time still does
not have WH one standard to be able to
fix that this particular problem so this
is some of the gap and there are a
couple of methodology out there that are
aiming at helping with answering some
filling some of these unmet need one of
these methodology is digital PCR so
digital PCR is not necessarily an
emerging technique in the pure sense of
the word because the first report of
digital PCR I go back to allens in the
early 1990s however
normal application of this methodology
is actually making its way into the
clinical laboratory and this is
exemplified by the fact that especially
in oncology digital PCR is a little bit
more frequently in microbiology because
of the challenges we had with some of
our assays we are now looking at digital
application of the diesel
PCR for infectious disease and I just as
a quick reminder the difference between
digital PCR and real-time PCR really
relies in the fact that unlike unlike
rates and PCR you don't really need an
external standard curve to quantify the
amount of DNA that you have for a
particular target more so it's also in
equal to amplifying DNA at the single
cell level so much so that you start
with you Tony NAU partition it into
wells or drug depending on the platform
is actually use and you amplify each one
of these target and dependency of the
other so there is this competition among
all the different target in a company or
in its solution and then as the word
says digital you sort of count the
number of wells that are positive for a
particle target with a different color
and these 2d scatter plot would show for
example that you have you know 10
positive well for something that's
neighbor with famine versus big and this
is how you essentially measure the total
number of targets that you have and in
that sense then you will hope that there
is more standardization across different
platform if we go back to our particular
case how does digital PCR help well
since we're looking at the integration
of the human which is v6 virus into the
human genome looking at a ratio of human
hosts versus the HSS it's virus is one
approach that some of investigator have
looked at to answer that question of is
it in actual infection or is it a
reactivation or is it in any of
integrated virus so a study that was
published by dr. Kim Jerome and
colleague on at Wash U shows that on the
designing primer for both HSV 6ne
ribonuclease which will be equals genome
you could look at a ratio of the agents
basics to the ribonuclease and determine
if that ratio will be suggestive of
integration or not so
you got example you did you could I had
your white blood cells and you perform
your PCR in a digital PCR there where
there's no competition between your
target you could count the number of
cells that had agency six in a number
target I had the RPP 30 host gene and if
this was only one to one ratio that was
success that the patient had integrated
bearers as opposed to an active
infection where the virus would be
replicating completely independently
from the host genome this was one
approach and when we look at this war
patron the poor blood sample had about
8,000 copy compared to the plasma so
remember that one of the way you could
look at this was much higher viral loads
in the patient however this was not
greater than 5.5 copies and if we had
had a digital PCR I say we could have
looked to see if there was a one-to-one
ratio but based on the methodology that
we had at the time the patient was
treated as if this was an HSV 6
reactivation but they really never care
and because of the many of the
probability it was it was suggested that
this was not integration for five in
axiom reactivation but better
methodology would have really helped
make the case for one or this this
particular syndrome in addition to it is
a set which is a very specific
application of digital PCR there's been
other suggestion of where digital PCR as
a method can really help for some of the
gap for infectious disease so for
example looking at self in human
papilloma virus um which then marries
oncology to infectious disease in terms
of being able to monitor for minimal
residual disease in plasma sample as
opposed to biopsy sample
absolute quantification so to help with
that standardisation of our testing
across lab in
Mycobacterium if you can again be able
to detect those very rare instances of
where it something's positive a mutant
in
larger set of positive Malcolm X M
tuberculosis organism you may be able to
have a better application of these and
um also for help with a standardization
of some of the reference material and
that I used to standardize on tests
across platform so if you can't that
hopefully this methodology would be able
to fill in terms of molecular diagnostic
the image that I should be earlier on
was that of a buyer an instrument
however there are multiple other
platform on the market to also look at
performing digital PCR and those are
listed here okay so we move on that to
chase number two and kiss number two is
that of a 70 year old lady I'm missing
the each year but this patient had AML
acute myeloid leukemia and was being
treated with chemotherapy and this will
diagnose is occur a few months before
the current presentation and so on the
presentation that is going to highlight
the cases here she presented to our
urgent care with a fever of 102 degree
and she also was suffering from a
urinary tract infections diarrhea and
dysuria so she was given some Sikaflex
the same but also we collected a couple
of blood culture on May 27 the day of
representation she was given drug and
I'd sent home and three days later for
both called shorter positive so just a
minute to think about this right because
it took three days for the blood culture
to to find positive and this patient
it really roses that take is very known
in acceptable on on time period because
the studies that have been published and
particularly this one by Kumari that was
published almost most are twenty years
ago at this point we show that early
recognition of sepsis is key in
preventing in
in preventing mortality from from this
particular syndrome so survival from
septic shock is directly related to the
duration of hypertension before
initiation of antimicrobial therapy so
because of that because it's so
important to get the patient on therapy
really quickly news on condition will
not you read for the result of a blood
culture to at least give the patient the
right antibiotic so right now we do a
lot of empiric treatment for processes
because of the limitation in some of our
current diagnosis so to meet you quickly
in your blood culture workflow start
specimen comes in the lab if you know
this basement is inoculated in a blood
culture at the bedside the blood culture
is sent to the lab the periodic
monitoring instrument and most blood
culture flags positive go to a Gram
stain and report a preliminary result of
in the ink in this particular case gpgc
standing from a positive oxide in
cluster right so we have your connection
because positive you get a Gram stain
and then you have your first preliminary
pause it may be a couple of minutes
later if your hours depending on the
methodology you have a report where you
have a specific organism in this
particular case we'll say staph aureus
and then you would take it a few more
minutes to get on a or a few more days
sometimes to get a report on the
susceptibility result to determine what
are the best drug to treat with that so
you can see from here that this takes
anywhere from hours to days to hours to
days so a patient like the one we had to
three days to get a results of positive
blood cultures so we already three days
here and then additional time for the
identification and susceptibility
testing so molecular diagnostic have
been very helpful in trying to move that
needle on closer to the time that the
patient was in however we still look at
this in terms of being able to do
molecular diagnostic from a positive
culture versus a positive specimen
process an actual specimen
and collected from the patient so if we
start with culture they are is series of
molecular diagnostic tests arm and they
can be in the amplification based or non
amplification piece that can be used to
facilitate the identification of an
organism but only once a bottle is
turned to positive so here I'm listing a
handful of those that goes from the very
simple like innovation looking at it
positive blood culture and couponing of
homes and looking for fluorescence so
one of the more recent platform so the
improved version of the fish where you
had a panel of organism that you can
look that you can test your positive
blood culture for in order to get an
idea of the organism and also some
susceptibility result so there are some
non amplification method and then
someone flick a measurement something a
based primarily on multiplex PCR and
depending on the platform it can be
quite extensive or really limited to
either just one target or two or to
anywhere as many as sometimes 30 orgasm
all right and so with this look at
molecular platform the impact has been
that once you have your positive blood
culture and you tune your Gram stain and
depending on the platform you may not
need to do a Gram stain you go from
anywhere from 20 minutes to a couple
hours to be able to get to give you
Tunisian Arizona so that's been very
significant in moving that timeline to a
little bit earlier so that your
preliminary report of Staph aureus is
much earlier and depending on the
platform you may even get on to provide
a susceptibility result in a time frame
that is actionable for patient and
condition the cost allows to be able to
instead of waiting for a blood culture
being able to grab it clinical specimen
from the patient and perform testing
directly on that clinical specimen
without the need for the pre incubation
for a blood culture
and today's only one molecular platform
has been able to accomplish that and
it's listed here the t2 biosystem
looking at this multiplex PCR I see that
takes approximately seven hours on to
turn around but you're starting directly
from a to me love blood sample and who
is series of steps being able to
identify if you gram-positive if you
have negative and some candidum so is it
here for the gram positive and gram
negative organisms will be the five that
you can identify by t2 and the five of
these that can be identified directly
from a clinical blood sample so with
that your work flow is even more in the
sense that you collect a sample you
don't have to wait a couple of days or
that it takes my blood culture to turn
positive you can have a result within
seven hours if you performing them as
you get the sample but in order to get
some information as far as what or what
trials to test with this you still need
the blood culture so this helps but
doesn't completely replaced anything so
if we go back to an Asian and the keys
on the isolate who's here identify s
fourthly a Miss Virginia Sun and the
patient was switched from thank you my
census my axon however is so this is
highlight some of the benefit that
multiplex PCR have brought to the
diagnosis of infectious disease
multiplex plants have allowed for more
rapid diagnosis especially when you
start from a positive blood culture we
don't need to isolate the iron the
organism before being able to identify
this however this is always so just
complimenting traditional diagnosis and
it's beneficial because you are able to
turn this on in time in in a few hour
and on depending on the methodology that
is years you can actually implement
targeted therapy for the patient but
arms there are still gaps that exist
because
as you can see from the previous image I
should highlight this just a picture of
like do microbiome of its human being we
have so many pathogen that the assays
that we currently have I'm not really
design to ten I get everything in the
designs that I get to make the most
common and our particular patient had
was posited by both Leah which is
actually not present on any of the
current commercial molecular tests so
this is an imitation of what we
currently have onto this been a change
in government we still have gap in being
able to capture anything that can make
difference X and the sensitivity of
direct detection from a blood sample is
relatively limited which is why the
majority of testing at this time Eastern
focus on detection in blood culture
sample one methodology that is emerging
is an option to solve this problem
is on next-gen sequencing so in this
particular study that was published in
this is actually an article review that
was published by pretty similar from
Hopkins about last year she compares she
does a good job of showing the
traditional workflow which we briefly
touched upon right you get your culture
you have to do ID to wait for things to
grow and so on and this takes anywhere
from a few hours to many hours and in
some cases on several weeks with whole
genome sequencing especially if you're
looking at an unbiased approach to
diagnosis you will be able to take any
clinical sample to your extraction
comparing it to DNA if needed the
library prep your sequencing which we
take you know about 24 hours but
depending again on your world could be
48 hours to your analysis and all of
these will replace all of these
different methodology and be able to do
this one test to come identify the
organs and then maybe other cause of
success right and you're just showing it
a different platform that are out there
right now in the market to be able to do
and sequencing so this will be one
application of moniker of an exploration
sequencing in infectious disease which
is metagenomic way it's an untargeted or
it could be targeted for bacteria so
let's say was 16s applicant sequencing
in this particular case it would allow
for increased sensitivity in the
detection of bacteria 19 all viruses
discovery of all the pathogen if you
were just doing meta-gene method genomic
science there's not apple with this
quick comb and application for ID is
also in terms of looking at all genome
sequencing and looking at potentially
directly on an isolate and getting
information that can even relate to
susceptibility of the organism for
targeted therapy challenges with NGS
however at this time is that it's still
not quite practical but we coming there
this is an emerging technology that has
a lot of hopes but the time still is
very long again might sort of be looking
at is patient where it was about three
days if you did three days for whole
genome sequencing result and that hasn't
really come to fruition completely this
is some challenge with bioinformatics
and data analysis the cost of the ISA
has come down however is still quite
significant compared to a blood culture
and there's still a lot of skills that
is required from clinical microbiology
laboratory to acquire to be able to
perform these tests and similar to what
we talked about it a profile
testing testing not really much the
organization for those who are
performing this test this is an emerging
technology is very exciting and we'll
see how this comes up as a as many of
these kids resolved you know this issue
gets resolved all the diagnostic that I
am urging that could fill this need and
this gap is CRISPR cast so Chris caucus
was discovered a few years ago in some
sort of modification of genetic material
but now this method is a value has been
evaluated and is shown to be
a potential approach to doing rapid
diagnosis for it from any sample and
looking for any toilet and you could
construct your guide RNA to detect
specific target and by doing this you
would be able to not only use this
methodology in a much more rapid much on
timeframe but this could also be
available for resource for setting of
point of care settings so again speeding
up the timing that it takes for us to
get this ID so CRISPR cards is another
diagnostic method for infectious disease
that we will keep our eye on just to
summarize on today's talk we really have
several existing technology that digital
PCR that's been around for a while but
now we are finding application in in
diagnostic for infectious disease we
also have emerging technologies such as
our genome sequencing or CRISPR God they
have the potential to really impact on
clinical care however we do still have
some gaps that are remaining but
hopefully in the next few years this
will become less of an issue and this
methodology could complement or replace
some of the a little bit cumbersome at
our traditional test that we are
currently doing so I'm gonna stop here
and I will be happy to respond to any
question that you may have once I
receive them by email so thank you very
much for your time and I will stop here
thank you and thank you dr. babbity for
that informative presentation I'd like
to thank lab routes for making today's
educational webcast possible as a final
reminder dr. babbity will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we will see you soon